okay here's a three main points i want
to tackle
um what's headless cms why go headless
and what are some of the headless cms in
that net core
space there are actually plenty of
powerful cms
for developing applications out there
but let me just focus on some popular
ones including the ones i'm familiar
with
i think that that net core is already a
versatile and great framework
but having a cms will allow for more
faster
developing times
hi everyone my name is ruby jane it's
just a brief intro of myself
i'm a freelance web developer based here
in norway
and here's my lightning talk on the cms
in.net core
what old is new again
so what's all this new again so yes
atlas cms
has been around for some time but while
headless and decoupled architecture are
nothing new
the demand for this kind of solution has
been increasing in the last few years
as companies look to deliver
to content of locations outside of the
standard web browser
so it is even projected that there will
be over 40 million
iot devices by 2022. so in short
multi-channel publishing is increasing
in
complexity and we need to keep up with
it to thrive
so what's in the cms so the term
headless comes from the concept of
chopping the head which is the front end
from or like the website off the body
which is the back end and for example
the content repository
and this means that the application is
built with an external api
so let's break it down a bit this image
is what i would say
sort of captures the idea of what said
the cms versus the
traditional cms the woman is the front
end
and the man is a back end and the waiter
is the api
as you can see old married couple which
i would imagine
to be a happily contented couple sort of
like the traditional cms
now prefers to talk to talk to each
other by the waiter
um okay here's maybe a better picture
again unlike a traditional architecture
in a hella cms
the front end and the back end are
completely separate systems
api given by a headless cms enables you
to distribute content to any channel
gadget and platform of your choice so
due to this approach
a headless cms um does not care
about how and where your content gets
displayed
um at the same time making it easier to
deliver content to different channels
so in the end being headless has only
one focus
storing and delivering your structured
content
controlling the connections so using a
headless cms you could push content to
just about anything from spa
to mobile app or even other cms
the big promise of the headless cms is
to enable you to reuse the same content
delivered through
different channels it let users create
and store content in a repository
but it doesn't take care of the delivery
of the content to web pages
or apps it's just raw content
which is available through apis usually
json
or xml or just about anything
creating the api or application
programming interfaces
so over the last decade apis have
exploded
essentially everything is driven through
apis
they are the community communication
standard that power everything on the
web
so what's an api um think of it as sort
of phone line between two
computers or computer programs um it's a
way for these two computers to talk to
each other
and share information regardless of what
handset they're using
so one good example of a use case for
headless cms
is when you deliver content to something
that is not
just a website or when you don't know
the web device
and all you have is an api integration
with that device
so why go headless um i think there are
many advantages of going headless
but foremost is that you can easily
integrate with
new technology and innovations
also um when a finance system is not
tightly coupled to the back end there is
no need to
update the entire system every time it
can be just part of the system
this way you can easily upgrade and
customize
your application without compromising
the performance
so some use cases for headless cms the
website is created with static site
generators
um not native mobile apps um
you can also enrich product information
on your e-commerce site
so headless cmsn.net core so obviously i
won't be able to mention every headless
cms
or the couple cms in.net core because
one
i don't have the time here and second
and most importantly
i don't know all of them so let me just
briefly discuss some of them
some i have experience working with and
with the rest i've
heard great things about so let's start
off with orchard core
um orchard core can be deployed anywhere
regardless of the platform
with container support it manages
content using graphql or res api
and it's multi-tenant means it offers
reusable website templates
making you manage multiple sites within
single installation
and it's also docker support
go foundry so co-foundly focuses on code
first development
so these are the requirements for
cloudfoundry and the simplest way to
get started is to create a web project
using the
net new command line tool it has docker
support
it has implementations for azure
services
via a plugin
piranha core so this is how you get
started piranha
um bananas is a totally packaged base um
using nuget and can be easily started
with that new
new template like this
screedx so like other headless cms
mentioned here
squids is also an open source it offers
rich
api with old data filter
and swagger definitions it has docker
support
and it offers good documentations and
samples on this site
and if you're interested to learn more
about it
braco hardcore so last but not the least
is umbraco hardcore
braco is actually well known um open
source cns
and hardcore is a full headless offering
or option
it has a built-in managed api so all
your content um
is automatically exposed via res api
um it offers webhooks and graphql api
it ships content delivery capabilities
using cloudflare
um so obviously there's still a lot of
headless and
decoupled architecture out there and
these are just the ones i'm
a little bit familiar with myself so
it's up to you if you want to research
more about
it and decide for yourself what best fit
your business requirements
and here's an end million pruner or a
millionaire question
so should we all just start chopping off
the head
because it has to be said that tell the
cms is not the magical thing
that can be fit um every business
requirements
but i think that chopping off the
presentation layer and
making your content available to one or
more than platform
should be a consideration whenever
possible or
applicable
so that's all for now i appreciate you
guys for listening and thanks to nbc
oslo for this opportunity
and as i say norway had a bra bye
stay safe and well